the number of coronavirus cases in
africa has surpassed
2 million including 48 000 deaths
africa's
infections and debts make up less than 4
percent of the global total but
the world health organization has warned
the continent is heading toward
a second wave of infections
africa has not experienced covet 19
infections on the scale that
experts had predicted but the threat of
a new wave
has raised fears that the continent is
not out of the woods yet
20 countries have had coronavirus spikes
in the past month
and that's for a range of reasons
[Music]
in most of the affected african
countries the rise in new cases is
coming from
workplaces and family gatherings and of
course we know that
there are several political elections
coming up in a number of countries
campaigns going on and gatherings as far
as
that is concerned and some existing
challenges have mounted
pregnant women in zimbabwe now have
limited access to medical workers
since many facilities are closed that's
in a country with an
already weak health care system
there used to be hospitals providing
cesarean sections for difficult birds
but then with covey now one getting
transport to get to the hospital was a
problem
so what happened a number of women were
struggling to give birth
and by the time they arrive in hospitals
they
actually are fatal they die
adapting to lockdowns is not easy or
affordable for many across
africa for example not every student can
do their online research
from home don't have the wi-fi at home
so waking up
daily and every day early in the morning
to go to kenya human rights commission
to access the wi-fi there it's a
challenge the moment i get to class
and i get access to the internet i
usually have time to
to like to cover up what others have
learned
news that a vaccine is near will be
welcomed
as much in africa as elsewhere although
there await logistical challenges
relating to how
it is rolled out
i am now joined by professor yap boom he
is with epicenter africa that's the
research arm of doctors without borders
he's a specialist in epidemiology and
public health
welcome back to dw news africa professor
so africa has now recorded two million
cases but
but i want to point out that france and
russia have just the same amount and
these are individual countries
uh their population sizes respectively
right 150 million
uh in in russia 67 million in france
this dwarfs africa's 1.2 billion so
what is your explanation for the reason
the continent seems to be doing better
than most
parts of the world thank you for
inviting me
again i think it's important to remind
ourselves
what do we mean by doing better is it in
term of number of keys
is it in terms of number of deaths so
definitely
the number of of case we need to
detect more and more of our in our
population
using the different testing uh that we
have but in number of cases we have a
different population i think we've been
mentioning that along and on we have a
population where the mean age of our
case is around 38 years old that's what
we see in cameroon in dlc in many
countries
which is different from what we are
seeing in most parts of the world
in europe or in china it was around 60
hours of age
and we know that the people who are the
most at risk
of having severe condition or even dying
are the older
and those having comorbidities which is
not fine as much in our population okay
that's it's interesting you point that
out because for example in europe and in
north america the
the second wave has been deadly what
would be the dangers of a second wave
in africa then
the danger i think beyond the sanitary
impact we
also have to look at the economical
impact because
if we have an important second wave as
you've seen in kenya for example if we
have
much more case than the first wave then
it will have an impact and country may
have to go to lockdown and we know the
impact that it has been having
in our population so our population
instead of dying from coffee they might
be affected by
lack of resource and some of those
people may be in the condition where
they cannot survive
okay professor there is um there is much
excitement right now about the the
efficacy of these vaccines
uh that are being developed but tell us
about the the potential challenges that
we might face
in distributing and administering the
vaccine in africa just from your
experience
with the ebola vaccine for example
you know during the the first time you
were using the ebola vaccine
that vaccine has to be used on the minus
80 degree and then we were using it in
three
countries and it was a very big
challenge now we have to roll out this
vaccine in all african countries we
definitely need to choose
which vaccine is adapted to our
environment
so we talk about the logistical
challenge the cold chain
we will rather go for a vaccine that can
be transported
at a normal temperature but also we need
to look at efficacy
90 of efficacy for a vaccine
for a disease that affect people like us
where we know that our
probability of dying is like one or two
percent
that's not that's not a lot especially
if we don't know the severe adverse
event
so i think africa will be more let's say
peaky
in choosing which vaccine should work
you know should we use in our population
okay professor ya boom thank you for
that insight